hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
hemoglobin a1c standardization
analytical performance and interference
of hb variants
i'm susie valdez of lab roots and i will
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott diagnostics
to learn more visit them at
www.abbott.com
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting
as many questions as you want at any
time you want during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
just click on that support tab found at
the right
of your presentation window or report
the problem by clicking on that ask a
question box located on the far
left of your screen now this
presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education
credit card tab located at the top right
of your presentation window
and follow the process to obtain those
credits i now present
today's speaker dr erna lenters-westra
an hba1c research technician
at isila clinical chemistry department
in zwolle
in the netherlands for a complete
biography of our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr leonard's webstra you may now begin
your presentation
welcome thank you for the nice
introduction welcome to you all all over
the world maybe in the morning or
in the afternoon or maybe even in the
evening i'm very happy to give this
webinar
well to be honest not really happy i
would have preferred to give this
presentation
live to you because i really really miss
the interaction with you all
but this is the best we can do right now
and i hope i can make this presentation
as
interesting as possible for you and if
you are a little bit bored
just look at the beautiful pictures i
have from our hospital in my
presentation
did you know that there are right now
425 million people with diabetes
and that one in two remains undiagnosed
maybe hba1c can help us to find these
people
these people with diabetes so that we
can treat them
but before we do that we need to
standardize
hba1c and that is the main
topic of my presentation today
the content of the presentation i will
talk a little bit about hba1c in general
i will talk about the ngsp harmonization
the ifcc standardization
different hbo1c methodologies and
interference of
hp variants and i will show you the
results of some
external quality schemes
well you probably all know that hba1c is
an independent parameter of the
metabolic control
it is also a risk parameter for the
development of complications
which has been established in two big
studies
the dsd study and the follow-up study
the uk pds study
i will talk about it a little bit later
from these two big studies we have now
the treatment goal in the disease
management
like if you keep your hba1c below seven
percent
or below 53 millimo per mole the chance
that you will develop complication is
quite small
what is also an independent
cardiovascular risk parameter in
non-diabetics
for example in our hospital every
patient with admitted submitted to the
hospital with a heart attack
or a suspicion of a heart attack we also
measure hpo1c
and if hpa1c is at the low end of the
reference range
the mortality and morbidity is much
lower
than when you have your hbo1c at the
high end of the reference range
in the netherlands it's also used to
assess the quality of diabetes care by
quality assurance programs like the
general physician
if the mean of all his patients is below
seven percent or below 53 millimole per
mole
he gets more money and it's now
also used as a parameter for the
diagnosis of diabetes
not in every country for example in my
country it is not used
yet officially but of course we all know
that
unofficially it has been used already
for many many years
but what about if you measure your hba1c
at the end of may what is then the total
influence on monthly blood glucose on
hbo and c
well as you can see here that if
something
happens in the last two weeks before you
measure your hba1c
when you are not that stable it will
have a big impact on your hbo and c
value but if you were not very stable in
february or march
the influence on hba1c
is not that high so this is something
you have to take into
account when you interpret the hbo and
see results
let's talk a little bit about hbonc
well the first hba1c method was
commercial available in 1978
but it took 10 years before the american
diabetes association recommends routine
monitoring
we have currently more than 100 hbo and
c methods and platforms available
or maybe even more because also point of
care instruments are
increasing considerably in the market
and there are more than 20 international
manufacturers
but also more many more national like in
china they have many
national manufacturers
and our different international and
national standards
the five different method principles are
cation exchange chromatography hplc
ornate affinity chromatography capillary
electrophoresis
immunoassay and enzymatic methods
before 2003 there was no reference
material available
which you can see in this graph from
randy little
this is the results of the colleague of
american pathology survey an external
quality survey
in 1993 they sent a sample
and you see that some labs are reporting
a result of 2.5
and others are reporting 7.5
so the interlapse fee was more than 20
percent
due to the standardization the ngsb
and ice disease standardization we have
now an
interlapse fee of approximately 3.5
percent
which is really really good why is it
then so
important to have this standardization
of course we want to have all the
results together but
we also want to use uniform clinical
guidelines
and we need this standardization to use
uniform reference values
but also to compare scientific studies
with each other so all the result all
the lab matters all over the world
it doesn't matter which method it is
which they should give
the same result
let's talk a little bit about the
american standardization
the which is based on the dst study this
study was about
1441 patients with type 1 diabetes
they were divided in two groups one got
the conventional care so
not that very strict and the other group
got a very intensive treatment with the
goal to get
the glucose values as low as possible
and have a low
hbo and t value and there was a
determination of the long-term
complication in both
both groups all the samples were
measured in one single core lab
using one method which is the hboc
method
this is why we are many times people
call
hplc the gold standard
because at that time it was a gold
standard because this hplc was used
in that very very important study but
it's not the gold standard anymore
because the routine methods have
improved considerably and they are
performing now
well even better than this hplc
the uk pds also measured hbo1c
and values were also directly comparable
to the dst
study while this is a very famous graph
you're all familiar with i assume that
if the hbmt is increasing
you also increase the relative risk of
developing complications
written or that is such a difficult word
to pronounce
nephropathy neuropathy and microalgae
so um so you have to keep your hba1c as
low as possible
also if you uh decrease your hva1c with
one percent or
11 millimole per mole we will have 20
less
21 less debts related to diabetes
or 37 percent less micro vascular
complications
or 40 percent less myocardial infarction
so it's very important so these studies
have been very important
this is how the energy speed american
standardization is organized
in the middle you see the central
primary reference lab
they are still running the hvlc the same
hvlc as being used in the dc study
then you have the secondary reference
lab they are running routine methods
here you see here you have all the
secondary reference slabs with their
secondary reference method
like in randy little elabs he has a
coordinate affinity hblc
and an iron exchange hblc etozo and a
premier
and another torso g8 in america
and biored variant 2 in china
and the ko500 hplc in japan
and this is the european reference
laboratory
this is my lab and together with another
lab in the netherlands we are the
european reference laboratory
in the other lab from kasweicom he has
an eigenexchange hplc minorini and
capillary electrophoresis
also an affinity chromatography but is
not certified
according to the ngsp i have a board
nate affinity premier
an immunoassay from roche enzymatic
assay
from abbot and i have the total g8
so we have all the different method
principles within the european reference
laboratory
what are the secondary reference lab
doing well they work together with
manufacturers by sending them
samples with assigned values but this is
not a real calibration it is a
harmonization
and we work together with manufacturers
to get an ngsp manufacturer
certification
and we use the secondary all the
secondary reference method to assign
values to external quality schemes
like the cap survey in america
but in europe we have different rules
the it says that the diagnostic
manufacturers must guarantee the
traceability of their routine tests to
reference methods
and materials of higher metrological
order
but this is not possible with the ngsp
standardization because that method is
not of a higher metrological
order and iso also demands documentation
about how to trace back assigned values
this is also not possible with the ngsb
primary reference method
this is the way how it really should be
done
this is the traceability chain you first
have to
define what you want to measure and with
hbo and c we said glucose attached to
the entail
internal fair line of the beta chain is
what we want to measure
then you have to develop a primary
reference method which we did
but this primary reference method need
to be calibrated with primary
calibrators
these primary calibrators consist of
almost pure a0
and almost pure hpa ones a1c
and in our lab we mix these two and we
calibrate the primary reference methods
with that
but these primary calibrators cannot be
used for routine methods you need to
have
secondary calibrators this is made in
our lab
the values assigned to these secondary
calibrators are done with
all the primary reference methods these
secondary calibrators
are used to calibrate my secondary
reference methods in my lab
but they are also sent to all the major
manufacturers worldwide
and they are using the secondary
calibrators to assign values to their
own calibrator
so eventually you can trace back the
patient results
to this primary calibrator and that is
very important
this is how the icc reference method is
working i will not go in very
detail but what you can see already is
that it takes
22 hours before you get one result
and that we are using an enzyme which
cuts after the
sixth amino acid of the beta chain
we have now 21 labs approved worldwide
who are running the icc
primary reference method we cannot
handle more labs
running the primary reference method but
i think 21 labs is quite
more than enough but the real
heart of the standardization is the
secondary reference material
every year i invite 100 patients with
diabetes
and i take blood from 15 of my
colleagues
i take in total 250 milliliter
in these big bottles
and from that blood we make 10 pools in
every pool there are at least 10
patients
these 10 pools are sent to all the ifcc
primary reference lab so the 21 labs
worldwide
but also to the secondary reference
methods from the ngsb
and the pools are sent to the
manufacturer so that they can use it to
assign values to their calibrator
and we use this blood also for the ngsb
certification
sets and foreign ifcc certification sets
so once the blood is drawn in our
hospital my colleague brings this to the
other hospital
in the netherlands to casual compass lab
they are very good at processing all the
samples
putting them in vials and send them all
over the world
and this is quite a challenge i can say
for many years we were not able to get
the blood
in time to japan so there was a lottery
every year
who of the technicians could bring the
samples
in the hand luggage to japan of course
with all the official papers
but we brought it in person to japan
because we had often that it was
released
too late from customs and then we could
not use the blood anymore
but we ended up with different results
between the ifc in the ngsp
if you would report it in the same units
you see that the ifcc method is giving
lower results
and not to confuse the doctors and the
patients
as a working group we decided to report
now in si units so millimole per mole
we have now the master equations between
the different standardization models
so you can calculate easily back from
ngsp to ifcc and vice versa
we check this master equation every year
so that we are sure that there is no
trend or shift
and that it is stable and we also have
now
the uniform reference ranges in
si units but also in ngsb units
so in summary there are two key groups
driving standardization and quality
one is the ngsp which is a harmonization
and the goal is to harmonize hbo and t
test results so that
clinical laboratory results are
comparable to those reported in the dct
where relationship to mean blood glucose
and risk for vascular complication have
been established
so harmonization not a calibration
because we don't have any calibrators
and we cannot trace back the result of
the patient
to a calibrator a more robust
and scientifically sound standardization
is the icc standardization
and the purpose is to standardize test
results
of all routine hbo1c essays worldwide
to the icc primary reference measurement
procedure so that patient results can be
traced back to a primary calibrator
in 2010 there was a consensus statement
and well the most important thing is
that they recognize that the ifcc
reference system is the only valid
anchor for standardization
and that hba1c should be reported in si
units and derived ngsp units
unfortunately
this is still not the case in many
countries
but there is an impact of changing units
on
imprecision i want to make this clear to
you
because it's quite important that
because you cannot compare cvs in
ngsp units with cvs in sr units and i
will explain you why
so if you have a sample and you analyze
it
15 times in ngsp units
and you calculate this fee is 1.9 you
take you do the same but then it is 5
units
then all of a sudden you see that the cv
is 2.7
how is this possible well this is the
reason why
this is a chromatogram of the primary
reference method from the ngsp
you can see already that the hbo1c peak
is not completely separated from the
front peak
so the underneath there is not only hbo
and c but also other substances
and this is really nice reflected in a
master equation between the iso c and
ngsb
because the 23.5 is the unspecificity of
the method used in the dst
study because if you add 23.5
to these numbers and calculate again the
cv
then you see it's exactly the same
so the most important thing you have to
remember is
you can not compare
cvs and ngsp units with cvs in sruis
because the cvs in ngsp
units are falsely low
well we also need to talk about
precision because it is as
important as standardization if you have
a method
and you analyze your sample and it's for
example
43 millimo per mole then you have a
method with the imprecision of one
percent
you are still okay then it is 42 or 43
or 44.
with two percent you are also still okay
but if you have a cv
of your methods up for four percent that
if you analyze it one time you can get a
result of 40
with a low risk if you analyze it again
then it might be 47 and then you have
diabetes
so that is the impact of imprecision
so you need to have a method with a low
as low as possible cv
so let's talk a little bit about the
different hva1c methods
we have different methodologies based on
separation
or chemical and with separation based on
different
in charge and orange structure hplc
cation exchange capillary
electrophoresis
of its structure affinity chromatography
and with chemical we have the
immunoassays and the enzymatic assays
all these methods they are standardized
according to the ifc standardization so
with the pools which we are sending
every year to all the major
manufacturers
so people ask me often what is the best
method
well the most suitable method depends on
the laboratory and clinical needs
because
if you have a lab with only 40 samples
to analyze per day
there is a different need than when you
have 4
000 samples per day so there is
it is different but cation exchange and
capillary electrophoresis are highly
highly reproducible and variants can can
be identified
affinity methods we use if there is an
interference of
hp variants because this method has no
interference of
hp variants only when hpf is higher than
50 percent
and the enzymatic and immunoassays can
be performed on general chemistry
analysis and
and have a higher throughput
but i want to say again
hplc is not the golden standard well in
fact
the perfect hbo1c method doesn't exist
all have their advantages and
disadvantages
the methods we have in our lab we have
the premier
athena quant total g8 and the abbott
enzymatic
and we have the ifcc primary reference
method in the other lab we have the
mannarini
uh we have the premier we have sevilla
capillary electrophoresis
and we have the isoscene and usb primary
reference method so we have all the
methods
in the european reference laboratory
affinity chromatography well it measures
total glycation
so when glucose is attached to
hemoglobin it will bind to the column
if there is no glucose attached to
hemoglobin it will go
through the column so eventually you
will get two
peaks a glycated peak and a non-glycated
peak and this methods
we only use what we mainly use if there
are hp
variants present because whatever is
happening in the hemoglobin
molecule it doesn't matter if glucose is
attached
you will analyze it
then there is ion exchange hplc if
glucose is attached to hemoglobin it is
just a little bit less positive adjust
so the delay due to the negative ions is
a little bit less so it will leave the
column a little bit earlier
capillary electrophoresis
well this is a really nice method
you have a really nice separation of all
the peaks
and what they do is that they only take
the a1c peak and a0 peak
they are not interested in all the other
peaks so it's quite specific
and has no interference so it's also
a very nice method immunoassays
first you hemolyze the the sample
then you photometric determination of
total hemoglobin
then you add an excess of anti-hbo1c
that binds with hbo1c and the excess of
anti-hbo1c is
caught by a
and this then there is a turbine metric
determination of antibody polyhepton
complex
well here you see my colleague well
it was quite funny because um when
i made the first first instrument from
rose it was an integra and i was making
this picture
and she said oh that is an unbelievable
boring picture you should do it in a way
like they're doing with
cars like with the pin up girl i said
okay you are going to be by
pin-up girl but
now we have the c5103 and they
the instruments are not that robust
anymore so and she gained a little bit
of weight so that's why she's here
it is a secondary reference method it's
also very simple method
method it's a dedicated instrument so
only hva1c can be measured on this
instrument
and it's uh well you i would recommend
only to use it in commercial labs where
you have
thousands of samples per day there's no
interference of the common variance and
disadvantage
or maybe the instrument is quite large
which is a
disadvantage can be a disadvantage
what is really nice is the antibodies
they are using
are against the last four amino acids
and glucose
attached to the beta feline
and if there is a variant present
you will have a substitution of the
amino acid the sixth amino acid for
when it is an s variant or c variant
also the sixth amino acid
e the 26th amino acid is a substitution
and for d the 121. so but the antibodies
are
against the last four amino acids so
there is no
interference whatsoever
only if there is a substitution in the
last four amino acids of the beta chain
you will have an interference and here
you see some examples of some
very very rare variants
then we have the enzymatic method from
abbas
i will not go in detail in the principle
of the enzymatic methods
the only thing you have to remember is
that they are using an enzyme which
cuts after the second amino acid of the
beta chain
and this is something you can measure
with a coloring
agent it is a very simple method
i really love this internet instrument
because it's so user friendly
this advantage or maybe it is also
uh quite big but on this instrument you
can also measure other parameters i
would uh
talk a little bit about this paper uh
i did an evaluation of the abbott
instrument
the c5 103 from rose and also
at the torso ga11 but i will use the
results of the abbott methods
well this is sick by metrics i could
also talk and give a presentation about
sigma metrics but i will not do that
in this graph you see that we have
combined
bias in this site with cv
i use the results of the abbot n sematic
from the icc monitoring program
24 samples 24 samples of values are
assigned with the
21 labs worldwide running the primary
reference method
and you see that the abbott method has
hardly any bias
also the cv is unbelievable low
and in the whole evaluation this is that
this one
it is well it is world class performance
of the abbott method
also now is the secondary reference
method in from the ngsp
and here you can see that the cv so the
imprecision
is well i couldn't believe it in the
beginning when i was running this method
that it was so low and
that it was so precise so i'm very happy
with this
here you see the icc certification also
it has a gold performance in the ifcc
certification let's talk a little bit
about
interference and hp variants i would say
the never ending story
well there are causes of interference of
hba1c
well you can have an inappropriate low
hpa1c
when the turnover of the red blood cells
is
is going faster than normally normally a
red blood cell
lives 100 to 120 days
so and then you can have an
inappropriate low hbo and c like bit
certain
hemoglobin nobodies or when you have a
recent blood transfusion or
acute blood loss but there's one thing
you need to take into account
are we talking about an analytical error
which might be the case if you have an
hb variant
or is it an interpretation problem and
most of the time
when you are talking about the
interpretation problem it has to do with
the turnover of the red blood cells
this was published last year in clinical
chemistry
and we had a patient with auto
antibodies
so also the turnover of the red blood
cells was much
faster and therefore the hbo and c
didn't correlate well with the mean
blood glucose
so it's estimated that 7 of the world
population carrying genes for hemoglobin
nobody and thalassemia
hemoglobinopathies is an abnormal
structure of the global chains
so you have the heterozygous but also
the homozygous what i want to say is
never analyze or
measure hbo and see when the patient has
a homozygous variant because it has to
do
again with the turnover of the red blood
cells
there's also a compound of variants
thalassemia is a quantitative deficiency
in the production of
hemoglobin alpha thalassemia beta
thalassemia and so on
and there are now more than 1500
structural hb variants
known so if you have
a mother and a father and they are a
carrier of a gene the hemoglobin variant
you they have 25 percent that they will
get
a child with the hp major
and this can be avoided if you use
uh the information from a whole a grow
metagram from
hboc if you see if the patient
is a carrier of a variant and you are
using that to generate for genetic
counseling
to avoid babies born with hpa
major that is in my opinion
the only advantage by if you see an hp
variant in your hplc
if you don't do anything with the
information no genetic counseling to
avoid this
then it has no added value to know if
there is a variant present or not
the only thing you have to know then is
will that variant interfere with your
method or not
so common heterozygous hemoglobin
variants in hairy detail persistence of
hemoglobin f
they are usually clinically silent and
they are widely spread
all over the world and a red cell
lifespan and repot to be in a normal
range
for most hb variants only talking about
hydrocyclohemoglobin variants not
homozygous
and the interference varies with a
specific method
let's have a closer look at hblc and hb
variants
this is the normal situation you have an
hpa
1c peak and a0 or peak and you can
calculate hva1c
if the variant the non-glycated variant
is separated from the a0 and the
glycated fraction from the variant is
separated from the a1c
you can have a very reliable hbm1c no
problem
but if there is an overlap anywhere
the results are not reliable
but the biggest problem is that if you
have a variant
which skips almost a normal grow
metagram
and and then you get an uh falsely low
hva1c result here you see an example of
mitoso this chromatogram looks almost
normal
but this is a glided e peak
and if the instrument doesn't recognize
this very small peak
you will get a falsely low hba1c
fortunately tozo recognize now
this small peak and so they can correct
for it and now it gives a
correct hbo and c result but there was a
problem
um my colleague randy liddle
as he did a big study and she found out
that all the toasters were giving
falsely low results with the common
variants after
a software update of their instrument
which was
not not very very good fortunately they
made an update of the software and there
is now not an interference anymore
but unfortunately this has to go to
fda approval so this new software update
is still not available
in america so you have to be very
careful with hp variants
and when you are used using a total
instrument
this isn't the result of an external
quality scheme from
england the assigned value is 35.3
the values were assigned with our
reference method in our lab
and you can see that the i in exchange
hblc were giving a falsely high result
because there was a variant present a
very rare variant
was likely you couldn't see it in the
grometogram it was hidden behind a
normal chromatogram
all the immunoassays they were
performing well
i made this a flowchart
to show the complexity of hbmc
measurement with cation exchange
hplc in the present of hp variants
you have to check every chromatogram
manually or by software in our lab we do
it by software
there we have put all the knowledge i
have in my head to integrate the
chromatogram into the software
if the chromatogram is normal you can
report hbo and c
but i have also shown you that some rare
variants are underneath and then you are
reporting it falsely if the chromatogram
looks like a normal well common variant
you can go to the website of the ngsp
and if the ngsp website says that that
method you are using has no interference
you can report it
but thus it has an interference you
should use another method like
affinity chromatography if the
grommetogram
is not like a normal or common variant
and is it a heterozygous then you can
also use affinity chromatography
and as as i explained already to you if
it is homozygous
don't use hvarmc don't report hbm1c
hba1c in hpf well hbf does not glycate
as fast as hbaa
and hbf consists two alpha two a comma
chains which is a problem for
immunoassays because the
enzymatic assays because they are
against the
beta chain antibodies against the beta
chain
if hpf is included in measurement of
total hemoglobin
the hbmt will be falsely low
hvo1 c matters where hbf is included in
the total hemoglobin are
immunoassays enzymatic assays and
affinity separation like point of care
and hpmc matters where hbf can be
separated from total hemoglobin ion
exchange and capillary electrophoresis
is it a real real problem well most of
these methods they
interfere if hba hvf is higher than
seven percent um hpf might be
um higher with a little better
thalassemia but never higher than seven
percent
you only have higher hpf when there is a
when you are talking about hairy detail
persistent fetal
hemoglobin yes i i have
rehearsed this but anyway
so i don't think this is a real problem
with all these immunoassays and
enzymatic assays
so hbo1c variants are the questions
which you need to
answer are you only interested in a
reliable hbo1c result
or do you also want information about a
possible hp variant
and if yes what do you do with the
information
do you use it for do you use the
information for genetic counseling
and you cannot make a diagnosis only
based on a peak in a grow metagram
the whole picture should be taken into
account
for a diagnosis if you have a sicker
cell
test the hbs and the sickle cell test
you have 100
certainty if you have a c or an e
variant and you know the
ethnic origin you have more than 90
certainty but to be 100 sure
there should be a confirmation of the hp
variant on dna level
so let's have a closer look at the
analytical performance with external
quality scheme i will show the results
of the colleague of american
pathology survey and our own your a1c
survey which we organize and
now in our erl lab
well sorry for all the numbers but i
will walk you through
here you see the five different samples
the values assigned are done with i
think now in total
seven secondary reference methods from
the ngsp
also our labs so the values are accurate
here you see all the different methods
and the number of labs using that
specific specific method
the mean of all these labs
using that method and the mean bias and
the interlab cv
what you can see here from the abbott
method that it is performing
really really well because if you have
an interlapsey fee
of 1.4 or even 1.1
then you are doing really a good job
also the the point of carry instruments
from
abbott are performing quite well if you
compare it with some other
laboratory-based methods
but i would like to talk with you also
about your a1c
which we have which we organize in our
hospital
it was published in clinical gamesc
2018.
how it is organized this is a try of
2019
well every on a sunday i
draw blood from 15 donors
diabetes persons i know them all by name
and every time when i ask them can you
please give me some blood
which which i need they always come and
why is that because i have a very good
relationship with all these donors
i know them by name and every year when
i see them it's quite a
kind of reunion so anyway
and we draw blood from non-diabetics so
we have two samples
we send these samples to all the
eqa organizers in the different
countries
and they distribute all the samples to
all the labs within their country
so we have now 3038 labs participating
with
threshold blood because there are also
some
countries who are not able to distribute
the samples within one week because you
have to analyze
the samples the fresh samples within one
week that is also why i draw the blood
on sunday
so we have one day we win one day with a
post and there are 1537 labs
participating with
leopoli samples the values assigned to
these two samples are done with the ifcc
primary reference method and with the
ifcc secondary reference methods
and also from the ngsb
here you see the results two samples
and the target value again all the
different
methods and the labs using that specific
method
the mean and the bias in the interlapse
v
again you can see that the ability
method the enzymatic method is
performing quite well
i think this is still also some immuno
essays
involved and to be honest i was not a
fan of
the immune essay of abbott because it
was absolutely not performing well
but fortunately they have now the
enzymatic method and you can see
that it is performing as the best method
when we are talking about imprecision
compared with all the different methods
but also the athenian point of care
instrument is performing quite well
i'm a little bit concerned about the
difference in bias between the
enzymatic methods and the point of care
but this is something
which need to be fixed in my opinion
what you can also do with the results in
sigma metrics you can
show the performance per country like
here so
two sigma is the uh the limit you have
to have
a sigma two or higher so you
see there are still some countries which
are not performing uh good enough
at least the mean you see the same with
the lyophilized samples
but you can also show the results uh
performance per manufacturer so
the different manufacturers you see some
are performing really really well but
also some
are not doing well at all this is a
very good information for the
manufacturers and also to show them
and to encourage them to improve their
methods
or take it from the market and the same
with lyophilized samples
but you can also show the results per
method
different instruments and so on
yeah there is still something to gain
like
the cbi is performing quite well
some rose methods are not performing
well
um but for manufacture this
is very valuable uh information
okay conclusions hplc is not the gold
standard for hbo and c
this came from the dst study
but that is a very old study and now the
routine methods are
most of them are equal performing
some hplc have significant problems with
some hp variants especially when hb
variant is present and the grow metagram
is normal a grow metagram can give
additional information about possible hp
variant but diagnosis of hemoglobin
nopaty
is not as simple as it looks
information of presence of an hp variant
should be used for choosing the right
hvumc method
and if applicable for genetic counseling
the abbott enzymatic method has no
interference of common variants
i want to thank you for your attention
and thank you dr lenters westrep for
that informative
presentation and we will now start the
live q a portion of the webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many questions as we have time
for
so let's take a look we already have
some great questions coming in
so our first question from our audience
member
is does a ngsp
certification or ifcc certification
guarantee a good performance of an
hba1c instrument
well to be honest no it gives
information to the manufacturer but it
doesn't say
anything about the performance in
routine labs
because an ngsp certification and ifcc
certification is done
under ideal circumstances and most of
the time with just
one instrument with one lot number and
with one calibration
so if you really want to know how the
performances of a routine matters
you have to look at the external quality
scheme
they will give you a real reliable
result of the analytical performance of
a routine method
thank you so much and dr winters westra
what is your opinion
on the best hba1c method
oh this is a question i often
get well to be honest i cannot say
because it depends on the lab it depends
on
how many samples you have if you have
just a
well 30 or 40 or maybe 100 samples per
day then it's very easy to run them on
hbo c you have time enough to check all
the grow metagrams no problem
but if you have more than 1 000 samples
per day
then it's almost impossible to do it
with hpoc
so then an immuno essay or an enzymatic
essay
is the best choice also
it is not only about the methods
it is also not only about the analytical
performance
but it is also about the support of the
manufacturer
because you can have the best performing
method but if
something is broken and the manufacturer
or the distributor is not going to help
you
that is also a big problem so there are
many factors you have to take into
account
and i would also recommend to
look at the external quality schemes how
the method is performing
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience members for these great
questions coming in
now do you think that one day we will
report
one unit like an mmol mol
in the whole world
i that is my dream that is really my
dream because
when we started with the ifcc working
group for the standardization of hbo1c
the goal was to have one reporting unit
eventually but after the consensus
statement was signed and
it appears that every country is
reporting
in the way they wanted to do it but
i am not happy with this at all because
it is
confusing also for manufacturers but
also for myself
if i have to write an article then i
have to
also write down in as i units but also
in ngsp
units and i know that it is many medical
doctors don't want to change the units
because they think it's very confusing
for themselves but also for the patients
but if we in europe are able
to make this change then it should also
be able
you should also be able in other
countries to make this change 2
millimole per mole
so yes most of the countries in in
europe they are now reporting in minimal
per mole
and other countries in asia like india
and other countries are now considering
also to make this change
and eventually i hope that
one day we will have one reporting
unit which is sri in millimole per mole
thank you so much and doctor launcher's
maestro we have time for one more
question
is it necessary to see if there is an
hb variant present
well i've i've told you already in the
presentation that
it depends on what you do with the
information
if you see that there is a variant
present and you
use this information for genetic
counseling so that
there will be no babies born with hb
major then yes it really has an added
value
but the problem is that many doctors
don't do any genetic counseling and they
don't use this
information so if you don't do anything
with the information
it has no real added value you only need
to know that if that pres
that hp variant has an interference with
the method you are using
but most of the routine methods nowadays
have no
interference of the common variants and
if you are not completely sure if your
method has an
interference i would recommend to go to
the ngsp website
they have a nice overview with all the
different methods
and if there is an interference or not
dr ventusvestra thank you so much for
your time today and for your important
research
would you like to provide any closing
remarks before we go
well i first of all i want to thank
abbott for the invitation
to to give this webinar even if i don't
like to give webinars so much i like
to give live presentations to have an
interaction
with all of you but i think
manufacturers have made a big
improvement in the analytical
performance
of their methods so i am really really
happy with this
also i want to encourage all all of you
who are listening to the
webinar if you have great ideas for big
studies or whatever
please do not hesitate to contact me
maybe we can set up something
and which is in the benefit of the
patients because that is the
only thing what is important me as a
researcher i am not important
also the manufacturers are not that
important it is
all about the patient and that is where
we are doing this great work for
thank you so much again dr lentes westra
it was
great to have you here and we'd also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
abbott diagnostics for underwriting
today's
educational webcast before we go i want
to remind the audience
thank you for joining us today and for
your interesting questions and questions
we didn't have
time for today and those submitted
during the on-demand period will be
addressed by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time take care
stay healthy
bye for now